الزميل محمد عثمان في الساعه التاليه ضمن
هذه التغطيه المستمره لهذه الليله الساخنه
محمد اليك نعم شكرا لك صهيب بطبيعه الحال
هي ليله ساخنه وساخنه جدا سواء كان في
فلسطين وايضا في
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا التصعيد الاسرائيلي متواصله
الليله في غزه وقبل قليل ايضا في لبنان
حيث افاد مراسل العربيه ان طائرات
الاسرائيليه استهدفت اهدافا في محيط مدينه
صور جنوبي لبنان واطلقت سته صواريخ على
مواقع قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انها تابعه
لحماس في محيط القليله جنوب لبنان
نعم ينضم الينا زياد حلبي مدير مكتب
العربيه في القدس اهلا بك زياد يعني يعطيك
العافيه هذه الليله ليله طويله الكل كان
يتوقع ان يكون هنالك رد اسرائيلي ولكن
ربما البعض بدرجه اقل لم يتوقع ان يكون
هذا الرد سريعا ايضا على الجانب اللبناني
جنوبي لبنان
طبعا نحن على الحدود مع لبنان صحيح هذا
الرد جاء بعد اجتماع الحكومه الامنيه
المصغره واعقب عمليا الرد الاساسي الذي
كان على قطاع غزه الغارات الاساسيه
ست سته صواريخ اطلقت من مقاتلات اسرائيليه
على موقعين على الاقل جنوب مدينه سور قال
بيان عسكري انها تابعه هذه المواقع لحركه
حماس
وعمليا بعد ذلك ساده هدوء حاليا التقديرات
بان هذا الموضوع قد يكون انتهى بمعنى
اسرائيل مررت هذه الرساله بانها ردت
بالغارات وليس بالقصف المدفعي كما كان
يحدث في الكثير من الاحيان خلا مره واحده
قبل سنوات ردت بغاره وعندها رد حزب الله
برشقى صاروخيه اليوم هي ردت بغارات باطلاق
سته صواريخ من مقاتلات اسرائيليه وليس من
باب المصادفه ابدا هذا الاسرائيلي
منهجي في كل البيانات التي تصدر بان
الاستهداف لحماس فقط او لمواقع تابعه
لحماس في جنوب لبنان
ربما بهدف ان لا يدخل حزب الله في هذه
المواجهه وان يبقى في من ان عن ذلك
وبطبيعه الحال اسرائيل لم تستهدف اي مواقع
تابعه لحزب الله او اي بنى تحتيه تابعه
للدوله اللبنانيه يمكن ان تقود الى رد
واسع من لبنان نعم سياسيا وعسكريا هل
اسرائيل هي مستعده لان ترسل كل هذه
الرسائل المزدوجه يعني يعني في هذا
التوقيت تحديدا زياد
اسرائيل فعلت ذلك لان معادله الرضع تاكلت
الى حد الانتهاء على هذه الجبهه في
السنوات الاخيره بدءا
بالتهديد تهديد حزب الله الذي عندما وقعت
اتفاق ترسيم الحدود مع لبنان ارسلها
مسيرات وهدد باستهداف منشات الغاز
واسرائيل عمليا
ذهبت الى الاتفاق واخيرا كان عبر
التسلل الى داخل اسرائيل مقاتل تسلل وفجر
سياره عمليا من قديمه من جنوب لبنان وما
الى ذلك ولهذا عمليا كان واضحا بان ثم
تردد سيكون اسرائيليا على الاقل بشكل رمزي
كي ترسل رساله اسرائيل انها تستطيع ان ترد
على هذه الجبهه رغم معادله الرضع القائم
منذ سنوات طبعا فيما يتعلق ايضا بقطاع غزه
الشيء ذاته عمليا اسرائيل ردت بغارات
مكثفه نسبيا
كما هنا حاليا في هذه الغارات
الرمزيه
المداولات في الحكومه الامنيه المصغره
طبعا طلب من الجيش الاستعداد لعده ايام من
القتال ليس بالضروره باننا امام ايام قتال
ولكن هذا في اطار التوقع السيناريوهات
المختلفه بان يستعد الجيش لايام قتاليه
على الجبل الشماليه هنا او الجنوبيه مع
قطاع غزه لكن الامور تبدو قابله هذا هذا
الصباح للاحتواء نوعا ما حتى على الجبهتين
يمكن ان نقول نعم زياد طيب هذا الردى
القابل للاحتواء وهذا الرد الذي يعني فهمه
البعض بانه رد محدود سواء كان هنالك في
قطاع غزه او حتى في جنوبي لبنان يعني
البعض يعني يتساءل اسرائيل ارادت ان ترسل
يعني هذا الرد المحدود لمن لحماس ام لحزب
الله ام للداخل الاسرائيلي هي تريد
اسرائيل بان تقول او الحكومه تريد ان تقول
للداخل الاسرائيلي انا انا موجوده وانا
استطيع ان اقوم بالرد
الوضع الداخلي الاسرائيلي بدون ان نشك
موجود في الاعتبارات لهذه الحكومه ولحظت
لاحظت بان البيان المقتضب جدا الذي صدر عن
المجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر شدد على ان
ما يحدث هو وفق توصيات
المؤسسه العسكريه والامنيه بمعنى حكومه
نتنياهو تدرك بان الشارع الاسرائيلي قد لا
تكون لديه ثقه ان خاضت حربا الا بعد ان
تقول بان هذا بناء على توصيات الاجهزه
الامنيه وليس بسبب الازمه الداخليه هذا من
جهه من جهه اخرى للخارج يعني وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي اقيل من قبل نتنياهو وعلقت هذه
الاقاله فقط لانه كان يدرك منذ اسبوعين
بان هذا السيناريو الذي نحن بصداده الان
موجود كان هناك انذارات استخباراتيه
بامكان اطلاق صواريخ من لبنان وبامكان
اشتعال الامور تماما في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وهذا ما حدث بشكل فعلي في
نهايه المطاف ول بالتالي اسرائيل ايضا
اهتمت وربما هذا ما يراه المراقبون بهذه
الرسائل
بالحديده والنار كي تقول بانها عمليا بان
يعني ان قرئ ما يحدث في داخلها ضعفا من
الاطراف الخارجيه فهي قادره على خوض يعني
مواجهه متعدده الجبهات ان كان في لبنان او
في غزه في الوقت ذاته لكن كما قلنا ايضا
الاشكاليه الواضحه في كل ما يحدث بالنسبه
لاسرائيل هو هذه المعادله التي فيها
الجبهات توحدت بشكل واضح بمعنى ينفجر
الوضع في المسجد الاقصى تطلق صواريخ من
قطاع غزه ينفجر الوضع في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله وفي داخل الخط الاخضر ومن ثم تطلق
صواريخ من جنوب لبنان هذا حدث في العام
2021 في رمضان ثلاث مرات اطلقت رشقات
صاروخيه من جنوب لبنان ربما الفارق هذه
المره هو في كم اطلاق الصواريخ يعني عشرات
الصواريخ 35 صاروخا تقريبا اطلقت كان اخر
الصواريخ على فكره التي اطلقت هي ثلاثه
صواريخ اطلقت الى هذه المستوطنه تحديدا
الحدوديه المطله
وبالتالي هذا هو المتغير الذي كان اسرائيل
الان بالنسبه لها يمكن ان تنهي المواجهه
مع جنوب لبنان
وربما بالنسبه لغزه الامر يبقى قابلا
للاحتواء هناك الان صفارات انذار فيس
ديروط وفي
مستوطنات غلاف غزه بمعنى الفصائل
الفلسطينيه تطلق الصواريخ سنرى المزيد من
الغارات ولكن نستطيع ان نعرف منذ الان كيف
ستكون النهايه في قطاع غزه وقف اطلاق نار
برعايه مصريه هذه المعادله التي ستكون ان
كانت الليله او كانت عمليا بعد حين وطبعا
الولايات المتحده هي على خط الوساطه هذه
المره وتضغط بشكل كبير منذ ايام عمليا
بهذا المعنى هناك وساطه مصريه وهناك ضغوط
امريكيه ايضا نعم طيب زياد ارجو ان تبقى
معنا مدير مكتب العربيه في القدس والموجود
الان في الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه ينضم الينا الخبير
في شؤون الاسرائيليه عصمه منصور عندما
تفتح اسرائيل هذه الجبهه الجديده في جنوب
لبنان ماذا يعني ذلك
هذه جبهه حساباتها مختلفه كليا اعتقد انه
فتح جبهه شامله مع لبنان وتحديدا ان يكون
المستهدف حزب الله او ان يكون هناك يعني
دور لحزب الله في هذه المواجهه هذا يعني
انه سيكون هناك تصعيد كبير وربما يمتد
لفتره اطول وتكون نتائجه يعني اكثر دماارا
سواء في لبنان لانه اسرائيل ستستهدف منشات
وبنيه تحتيه وستحمل الدوله المسؤوليه
والجيش لبنان المسؤوليه وايضا من قبل حزب
الله الذي سيرد بصواريخ دقيقه وربما لمدى
طويل لكن ما لاحظناه هذه الليله في هذا
القصف انه لا يستهدف حزب الله هو استهدف
مواقع التي اطلقت من الصواريخ وقال انها
يعني مواقع تابعه لتنظيمات فلسطينيه او
لحركه حماس لذلك لهذا يبقى في اطار
التصعيد المحدود او المحصور جدا والغير
واسعه وهل هذا الامر يقلل من فرضيه رد حزب
الله
حزب الله لا تكون يعني مثل الحباس وغزه مع
خطوره طبعا ما يحدث هناك ولكن هنا يكون
وكانها مواجهه مع ايران مباشره وكانها
مواجهه مع محور كامل وامكانيات حزب الله
وقدراته الصاروخيه
واعتاده
وتعداده يعني مختلف كليا وايضا خبرته
القتاليه وهذا جربته اسرائيل في ال 2006
يعني ستحتاج الى مسوق كبير واخلال كبير
بالمعادلات كي تكسر هذه الحاله القائمه
انا افترض انه تصعيد الاكبر سيكون في غزه
وايضا ربما اهداف شخصيات طيب استاذ عصمت
يعني هذا القصف على قطاع غزه يعني هذا
المشهد تكرر كثيرا خلال السنوات السابقه
وهو ياتي من باب تجريب المجرب لكنه لم
يفضي الى نتائج ملموسه وعمليه على ارض
الواقع يعني هل هنالك امكانيه في هذا
التوقيت وفي هذا الظرف هل هنالك امكانيه
للحلول السياسيه على الاقل تهدئه الاوضاع
انا اعتقد نعم هناك امكانيه هناك قنوات
مفتوحه وتعمل
رسائل ووجهات نظر وتصورات وايضا ضغوط على
الاطراف ما نراه ايضا يعني بحذر نقول ما
نراه حتى الان هو لا يمشي بتصعيد بعيد
المدى لا يشري بكسر قواعد اللعبه اسرائيل
تركت ضربه موجعه مباغته ومن جبهه يعني
صحيح انه كانت تتعهد بامكانيه تصعيد من
الجبهه الشماليه ولكن لم تكن تتوقع ان
يكون بهذا الشكل وهذه السرعه وهذا العدد
من الصواريخ لذلك هي سترد وهي تدرك انه
حتى ردها يعني كما قلتم هو يعني حلقه
مفرغه
ستقصف ستدمر ربما تستهدف مواقع ربما ابراج
وغيرها كما فعلت قبل عامين ولكن في
النهايه ستقف عند نفس النقطه التي وقفت
عندها في الجوله السابقه والتي ستقف عندها
في الجوله التي تليها يعني الحل ليس
عسكريا العنف السياسيه فقط نعم الحل سياسي
تماما طيب اذا نحن نتحدث عن كما ذكرت انت
قبل قليل وتحدثنا سابقا في خلال هذه
التغطيه عن ان نتحدث عن فعل محدود ورد فعل
ايضا بالمقابل من الفصائل الفلسطينيه هو
رد فعل محدود وحتى الان نحن نتحدث حتى
الان معنى من غزه الصحفي نضال الخضراء
اهلا بك الى هذه النشره ضعنا في صوره ما
يحدث الان في غزه المشهد الان في غزه بعد
الحديث عن يعني الهدوء الحذر الذي يعم كل
المناطق وعموم المناطق في قطاع غزه
يعطيك العافيه تحيه لكل مشاهدي العربيه
الحدث قبل نصف ساعه
اطلقت فصائل المقاومه رشقه صاروخيه باتجاه
[موسيقى]
الغلاف من من شمال غزه
الطيران الحرب الاس
رائيلي ايضا استهدف موقع للمقاومه وسط
قطاعي غزه
وهناك
تدمير
لبعض المنازل جراء الغارات الاسرائيليه في
في بعض المنازل شرق مدينه غزه ايضا وهناك
طائرات الحربيه تقصف او قصفت
موقع شرق رفح على الحدود مع مصر
والطيران الحرب الاسرائي
لي يقوم في اجواء كبار غزه اضافه لطيران
الاستطلاع يهدا
منذ منذ يعني تقريبا منتصف الليل الى حد
هذه اللحظه يعني هناك الان هدوء هدوء حظر
الان نحن يعني في حاله ترقب
هل ستقوم المقاومه يعني بالرد لحد هذه
اللحظه
كما قلت لك في نشرات سابقه يعني لم تتغير
قواعد الاشتباك بين المقاومه في غزه وبين
صواريخ المقاومه لم المقاومه لم
تصف
الداخل الفلسطيني بتواريخ استراتيجيه
المدى من الممكن ان يصل الى عسقلان وبماذا
تفسر ذلك
نعم نعم يعني اود ان اسالك بماذا تفسر ذلك
يعني وقبل ذلك اود ان ان اشير الى هذا
العاجل اليونيفيل تقول ان اسرائيل ولبنان
لا ترغبان بالدخول في حرب اذا يعني هنالك
رغبه من اسرائيل ومن لبنان كذلك لعدم
الدخول في في حرب اود ان اسالك الى ماذا
يؤشر المساله عدم يعني الرد بشكل كبير من
الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وارسال صواريخ الى الداخل الاسرائيلي
يعني من
ذ مره عندما بدات بدات قمه قمه شرم الشيخ
وبعدها قمه العقبه بدات تحرك رؤساء اجهزه
المخابرات
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه والمصري الاردنيه بزيارات
مكوكيه الى الى رام الله والحديث
الفلسطينيه وتم استدعاء وفد من حركه حماس
والجهاد الى القاهره وتم الحديث
وهذا يؤكد ان هناك رغبه وهناك هناك رغبه
من الاداره الامريكيه بتهدئه الاوضاع
لتحسبها ان ان هذه الحكومه الفاشيه من
الممكن ان تقدم على يعني افعال
استفزازيه في شهر رمضان المبارك
الامريكان
منشغلين في في في قضايا
من الواضح ان هناك عدم رضا على حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهم
بالتصعيد باستراتيجيه لا يخدم اسرائيل
اسرائيل في الوضع الداخلي الاسرائيلي
محتدم
مالات المواجهه لا سيما في ظل حاله
المستوى المكسيك والتنسيق بين محور
المقاومه الذي بدا واضحا سواء في حماس
والجهاد في فلسطين وحزب الله بدا واضحا
هذا التنسيق
اربك اسرائيل بدليل كما قلنا انه من الصعب
ان تذهب اسرائيل بمواجهه مفتوحه على
الجبهه الشماليه لانه مالات هذه المواجهه
ستكون
لا تعلم اسرائيل عقباها بعد التجهيزات
التي التي بدات
بدات بعد حرب
بعد حرب تموز اضافه الى الحاله التي
اوجدها اوجدها الايرانيين في الجولان وهي
حاله استنساخ عن حزب الله
اضافه الى التهديد الاستراتيجي الذي يعني
يهدد حقول الغاز في شرق المتوسط في ظل
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
لاسيما ان
النسبه الكبرى من من الغاز التي الذي
تسيطر عليه اسرائيل في شرق المتوسط من
خلال الحقول هو يعني يصدر الى اوروبا
وحزب الله لديه القدره على
ضرب هذه
هذه المحطات في شرق المتوسط سواء من خلال
القوه العاليه
للمسيرات
الايرانيه
المتقدمه
فلذلك موضوع الهجوم بحرب مفتوحه على
الشماليه كان مستبعد وما زال مستبعد لذلك
لو نعم يعني وسائل الاعلام عينها الان على
ما يحدث داخل قطاع غزه وعين اخرى على ما
يحدث في جنوب لبنان
وترقب لما يمكن ان يحدث بعد صلاه الجمعه
في المسجد الاقصى على اعتبار ان الجميع
يتوقع بان يكون هنالك ربما حاله تصعيد
يعني في المسجد الاقصى بعد صلاه الجمعه
اثر ما حدث في هذا القصف على قطاع غزه
القضيه الخطيره هنا ان المستوى الامني
والمستوى العسكري في دوله الاحتلال
يوجد يعني غير راضي عن تحركات الحكومه لا
سيما وزير الامن
الامن او الامن الداخلي ثمار بن كبير هذا
متطرف نعم استاذ نضال الخضراء يعني
استاذنك في قراءه هذا العاجل القبه
الحديديه تعترض صاروخين فوق مستوطنه
اطلق من قطاع غزه نتابع هذه الصور
نعم نعم
هل هل الحكومه هل الاجهزه الامنيه ستستطيع
ان تكبح جماح ثمار بن كبير الذي يدعم
منظمه عائدون لجبل الهيكل التي اعلنت انها
ستقوم
بذبح القرابين في في المسجد الاقصى
التي دعت اليوم من خلال من خلال
اكثر من من بيان تم توزيعه في
الاعلان لدى المستوطنين في القدس وفي
الضفه الغربيه هناك حاله من التباين
وازمه واضحه في في
المؤسسه الامنيه الاسرائيليه كونه ابن
كبير هو وزير في هذه الحكومه وزير امني
وهناك اجهزه امنيه
وتحديدا الاجهزه الامنيه هي صاحبه اليد
لانه لديها مؤسسات استراتيجيه
كجهاز الشباك
جيش الذي يعترض على سلوك
الثمار بن كبير الذي
يمين نتنياهو اخر الابتزازات التي تمت في
تاجيل مشروع الاصلاح
بتشكيل قوه امنيه معزن عن قوى الامن
الداخلي وبمعزة والاجهزه الامنيه وهذا
وهذه ميليشيات جديده من الممكن ان يشكلها
مستوطنين فهذا دليل واضح ان نتنياهو لديه
ازمات كبيره وهناك ازمات كبيره في
في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي لذلك
الجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه هي ليست
موحده وهي ليست مؤهله ان تذهب بمواجهه
مفتوحه سواء مع قطاع غزه
او مع مع لكن انا بتقديري انه من الممكن
ان المتطرفين في هذه الحكومه
ان يقدموا على افعال تجبر اسرائيل ان تذهب
الى مواجهه
والمواجهه هذه المره ستكون مختلفه لانه
بدا واضحا ان هناك قرار استراتيجي لدى قوى
محور المقاومه بوحده الساحات وبوحده الرد
وهذا وهذا وعطفا على ما ذكرته لك قبل قليل
نحن نتوقع سيناريو معين ان يكون اليوم عقب
صلاه الجمعه في المسجد الاقصى
يعني انا بتقديري يعني الاجهزه الامنيه
وجيش الاحتلال يحاول ان
من خلال التصريحات يحاول ان يعمل على
تهدئه الوضع وان يمنع المستوطنين
والمنظمات من الدخول الى الى المسجد
الاقصى ولكن هل يستطيع الجيش ان ربما يؤدي
لمزيد من التصعيد كذلك يعني بالتاكيد
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد لا سيما ان ظل التحركات
المكوكيه والحوارات
بين الوسطاء وما بين فصائل المقاومه
اكدت فصائل المقاومه انه هي ستلتزم في حال
التزمت اسرائيل بعدم الاقتراب من مسالتين
ملف القدس الذي يشكل حساسيه كبيره لدى
فصائل المقاومه و ملف الاسرى قبل
ما يقارب
اسبوعين في بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك
اعلن الاسرى
الاعلان عن الاعلام عن الاضراب عن الطعام
نتيجه الاجراءات التي اتخذها الوزير
اعتمادبير ولكن
قامت الحكومه باحتواء وقام بهذا الشباك
باحتواء هذه الازمه بتحقيق مطالب الاسرى
وتم احتواء الموقف على العلم ان كان هذا
الملف يعني
سيفجر المواجهه بين فصائل المقاومه وما
بين اسرائيل مما يؤكد ان اسرائيل لا ترغب
في مواجهه الان مع قطاع غزه لانه هناك
كثير من البيانات الوارده كانت في الفتره
السابقه
ان اسرائيل لا ترغب في المواجهه وهذا ما
اعلن عنه رئيس جهاز
من ماذا تخشى لماذا تخشى المواجهه في هذا
التوقيت
والموضوع الموضوع الموضوع ليس يعني قضيه
ان تخشى هناك حسابات اسرائيل الان حسابات
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
وهذا ما شهدناه من خلال
الاقتحامات المستمره برغم التزام السلطه
الفلسطينيه هناك
وذهابها الى تلبيتها لدعوه الاداره
الامريكيه في قمه العقبه وقمه شرم الشيخ
الى ان الاسرائيليين وجيش الاحتلال
مستمر في عدوان الضفه الغربيه يعني عندما
انت ترى ان السلطه الفلسطينيه تتعرض الى
ضغوطات لتاجيل مشروع القرار الذي يعني
يدين اسرائيل في مجلس الامن وفي اليوم
التالي تدخل الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه
وجيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي باقتحام مدينه
نابلس واغتيال عشره شهداء هذا ما يؤكد ان
هناك
انسجام بين المؤسسه الامنيه والمؤسسه
العسكريه وبين الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بعكس ما نسمعه ان هناك تبادل في الضفه
الغربيه لا يوجد تبعهم لذلك المعركه
القادمه في الضفه الغربيه واسرائيل منشغله
في القدس وفي الضفه الغ ربيه قطاع غزه
يعني اول شيء هي منطقه شبه تماما
وقطاع غزه او قوى المقاومه في قطاع لديها
لديها يعني ما يزعج اسرائيل وما يعكر
مزاجها شئت ام ابيت يعني يعني بغض النظر
عن عن حجم الخسائر لكن اسرائيل دوله يعني
انت في لحظه ممكن انت تنيم 2 مليون مستوطن
في غلاف غزه في الملاجئ هذا موضوع يعني مش
سهل
واضافه الى تطور امكانيات المقاومه من
خلال
الطائرات الاستطلاع طائرات الاستطلاع ومن
خلال المسيرات ومن خلال
الصواريخ بعيده المدى التي اصبحت يعني تصل
الى الى كل فلسطين المحتله
في كل الاماكن فالموضوع
الموضوع مكلف واسرائيل لا تريد ان تنشغل
يعني تريد يعني تريد ان تفصل وهذا ما
سمعناه من تصريح تصريح
الناطق جيش الدفاع انه
القصف في قطاع غزه مش مرتبط في في الحدث
اللي صار في جنوب لبنان او في اطلاق
الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان على مستوطنات في
الشمال انا اتمنى ان ابقى معنا يعني اتحول
الى مدير مكتب العربيه في القدس زياد حلبي
يعني
قبل قليل انت يعني بعثت بعواجل اطلاق رشقه
صاروخيه من قطاع غزه تجاهها المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه الحدوديه هل من تفاصيل
هذا صحيح يستمر اطلاق الصواريخ بشكل متقطع
تجاه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه الحدوديه من
قبل الفصائل في قطاع غزه جرى اعتراض
المزيد من الصواريخ قبل قليل بواسطه القبه
الحديديه كان هناك عمليه اعتراض في منطقه
سديروت وايضا مستوطنات صغيره محيطه تعرضت
لاطلاق الصواريخ بهذا المعنى الامور ما
زالت بين اخذ ورد على جبهه قطاع غزه فيما
ان الهدوء يسيطر عمليا على جبهه لبنان
حاليا
نعم طيب زياده يعني اذا نحن نتحدث عن
اطلاق صواريخ من غزه باتجاه مستوطنات
الغلاف لا ادري اذا كان هنالك صور من
الزملاء هل هنالك صور
طيب زياد
نعم هذه هي صور الان
لاطلاق صواريخ من قطاع غزه باتجاه
مستوطنات الغلاف اذا نتابع الان يعني هذه
صور التي وصلتنا الان نستمع الى صوت
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
اذا نعود للزميل زياد ان كان معنا زياد
الان
زياد ماذا نتوقع اليوم يعني بعد صلاه
الجمعه في المسجد الاقصى يعني ربما تكون
هنالك حاله تصعيد ايضا بالنظر الى ما حدث
اليوم في قطاع غزه ما حدث من الرد
الاسرائيلي وهذه
الغاره الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه وبالتالي
البعض يتوقع بان يكون هنالك حاله تصعيد
كبيره جدا بعد صلاه الجمعه في المسجد
الاقصى
هذا وارد ان يكون في صلاه الجمعه الثالثه
في رمضان بفعل التصعيد الحاصل الذي كان
بدا بالاعتداءات في المسجد الاقصى والان
القذف هذا القصف على قطاع غزه يعني قد
يؤجج ايضا المشاعر وبالتالي يمكن ان يتوقع
ان يكون هناك نوع من التصعيد هذا اليوم
ايضا في القدس الشرقيه
المحتله بهذا المعنى هذا صحيح
وطبعا قد تكون هناك اجراءات اسرائيليه
خاصه فيما يتعلق
الان صلاه الفجر وما الى ذلك اذا كان هناك
ايضا توتر وتصعيد واعتداءات فهذا قد
يوصلنا الى نوع من التوتر قد يواكب ايضا
صلاه الجمعه الثالثه من شهر رمضان عاده في
مثل هكذا مواقف ومثل هكذا مواجهات ما هي
التدابير الامنيه التي تقوم بها اسرائيل
في حدود المسجد الاقصى
نعم طيب زياد يعني
اود فقط ان ان اشير واذكر ايضا الى ان
حاله التصعيد ربما تستمر كما ذكرت انت قبل
قليل وربما تصل ذروتها في صلاه الجمعه
بتدابير الامنيه التي تتخذها اسرائيل لمنع
يعني اعداد كبيره من المصلين من الوصول
الى المسجد الاقصى في هذا اليوم يعني
تحديدا اثرى ما حدث بعد الغارات التي
شنتها اسرائيل على قطاع غزه يعني
دعنا نتحدث سياسيا يعني وكنا قد طرحنا
سؤال ما هي الاوراق التي تملكها مصر او
الوساطه المصريه الامريكيه في الضغط على
جميع الاطراف على الاقل للوصول الى درجه
التهدئه زياده
هذا صحيح مصر
التقليديا هي المؤهله للاعب هذا الدور
دائما لان لديها نفوذ قوي جدا على الاطراف
وتؤثر على الطرفين عاده بهذا المعنى هي
منذ الدقيقه الاولى تواكب الموضوع بطبيعه
الحال في الساعات الاولى اسرائيل كانت
ترفض ان توقف العمليات لانها هذا القرار
كان كما قلت كان هناك هدف اسرائيلي بان
يكون الرد مغايرا او ان يبدو على الاقل
مغيرا عن الغارات العاديه التي تقوم بها
ردا على اطلاق الصواريخ من حيث الحجم
والكميه اطلاق الصواريخ اتجاه الاهداف في
قطاع غزه لكن مع مرور الساعات هذه الوساطه
تبدا بانتاج النتائج عمليا انجاز التعبير
هكذا بهذا المعنى ايضا كما قلنا الولايات
المتحده تضع ثقلها
لاحتواء الوضع ان كان على الجبل اللبنانيه
او على جبهه قطاع غزه والضفه الغربيه
والقدس المحتله تحديدا هناك ضغوط على
اسرائيل في هذا الاطار بضروره منع التصعيد
الشامل الذي كاد ان يكون عمليا نحن نتحدث
هذه هذا اليوم عن هذه الجبهات المتوتره او
المشتعله في اكثر من مكان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وايضا مع جنوب لبنان وان كان
الوضع هنا يبدو على هذه الحدود بانه الى
انتهاء عمليا في حال لم يرد حزب الله هذا
قد ينتهي وفي حال تاكد عدم وجود اصابات في
الغارات التي شنتها اسرائيل كما قلنا
اطلقت سته صواريخ من المقاتلات على مواقع
قالت انها تابعه لحماس لم يكن هناك اصابات
او ضحايا هذا يعني يعزز الانطباع بان
الامور قد يعني تقفل على هذه الجبهه بشكل
سريع بالنسبه لجبه قطاع غزه كذلك الامر
على الرغم من استمرار التبادل القصف
والصواريخ دائما يمكن ان تتوقف هذه الجبهه
في اي لحظه عمليا بوساطه مصريه نعم هناك
الاصابه طبعا مباشره في بيت في مستوطنه
سيدي
نعم ارجو ان
اصابه نعم اليك الكلمه
نعم نعم كنت اقول ان هناك صاروخان سقط
اصاب شقه في مبنى في
مستوطنه هناك اصابه لمستوطن بجروح طفيفه
حاليا وفقه المعلومات
الراشحه هذا قد يعني يطيل قليلا المواجهه
وتبادل القصف ما بين المقاتلات
الاسرائيليه والصواريخ الفلسطينيه نعم
يعني حتى الان نحن لا نتحدث عن يعني
مواجهه مفتوحه ما بين الجيش الاسرائيلي
وايضا يعني الفصائل الفلسطينيه على الاقل
في قطاع غزه صحيح
صحيح جدا والا كنا راينا الاستهداف وصل
الى بئر السبع والى التل ابيب والى مناطق
اخرى بهذا المعنى الواضح منذ البدايه بان
الفصائل كانت تدرك بان اسرائيل غير معنيه
بحرب وبالتالي سترد لانها عمليا بعد اطلاق
هذا لهذه الكميه من الصواريخ التي اتهمت
بها حماس واساسا لان لديها حساب مفتوح من
الاطلاق الصواريخ الاخير الذي تم من قطاع
غزه واسرائيل لن ترد بسبب عيد الفصحى
اليهودي الذي صادف اليوم هذا كان متوقعا
وبالتالي الرد الفصائل الفلسطينيه كان في
مدن قصير جدا في الاستهداف وصل الى جنوب
عسقلان بهذا المعنى لم يكن تصعيدا كبيرا
كما كنا نرى في السابق ان المواجهه كانت
تبدا احيانا باستهداف تل ابيب وهذا طبعا
لم يحصل هذه المره
لهذا يجوز الافتراض بان الامور قد تكون
قابله للاحتواء نعم اتحول الى الخبير في
الشؤون
الاسرائيليه الاستاذ عصمت منصور هل صحيح
التوصيف الذي ذكره زميلنا زياد الامور
قابله للاحتواء سياسيا وميدانيا ايضا
انا اتفق تماما ما قاله الاستاذ زياد
اسرائيل ولاسباب كثيره داخليه ولها علاقه
بالتوقيت اعياد وشهر رمضان وايضا بسبب
الظروف في الضفه وايضا وحده الساحات التي
تحاربها ولا تريد ان تكرسها اكثر واكثر في
مواجهه من هذا النوع وايضا بسبب ربما عدم
وجود غطاء امريكي كافي اذا كان هناك تدخل
الامريكي لوقف التصعيد امريكا تملك اوراق
كبيره في التاثير على الموقف الاسرائيلي
لكل هذه الاسباب وايضا لتداعيات المواجهه
المفتوحه
وكلفتها الاقتصاديه والبشريه
وعدم تحقيق هذه مكاسب ربما تخرج بدون صوره
انتصار واحده اسرائيل كل هذا يجعلها ربما
تسعى الى هذا الامر ولكن نقول هذا بحذر
شديد يعني دعنا لا نجزم ربما حدث صغير ان
ينزلك صاروخ ويصيب منزل كما حدث الان
ويؤدي الى قتله هذا يعني ربما يعقد
المساله
ابدا المواجهه وربما كلما طال امدها ولو
ساعه واحده هذا الاحتمال يزداد بان تقع
خسائر غير محسوبه وتجعل التراجع
الاسرائيلي اصعب وايضا بالمقابل ربما
بالطرف الاخر ربما بالطرف الفلسطيني يكون
هناك عدد كبير من الشهداء وبالتالي هذا
يدفع الى توسيع مدى الصواريخ وتتدحرج
الامور حتى يعني كثير من المواجهات وفي
تاريخ الصراع والمواجهات بين قطاع غزه
واسرائيل مواجهات بدات بدون رغبه من
الطرفين ولكن فرضت من خلال التدحرج بهذا
الشكل
وتوسعت وامتدت لايام وربما اسابيع بعض
وهذا نموذجا يعني يتدحرجت الامور منذ ان
بدات القوات الاسرائيليه باقتحام باحات
المسجد الاقصى تدحرجت الامور الى ان وصلت
الى هذه الدرجه صحيح
هذا مثال حي على هذا الامر ولكن ربما حتى
الان يمكن السيطره طالما انه القصف في
نطاق غلاف غزه وطالما انه القصف
الاسرائيلي في نطاق مناطق مفتوحه ولا
يستهدف لا ابراج ولا منشات حساسه ولا ولا
مدنيه انا اقصد هنا يعني ربما يبقى هنا
امكانيه السيطره قائمه لكن اذا يعني
تدهورت الامور يصبح التراجع اصعب ويصبح كل
طرف بحاجه الى صوره انتصار او يعني لحظه
يعلن من خلالها تحقق اهداف هذه المواجهه
وعلما انه اهداف هذه المواجهات هي لا
علاقه لها بالتدمير ولا علاقه لها بالقصف
لا علاقه بالوعي ومن يستطيع ان يكرس في
وعي الجمهور لديه انه هو الذي انتصر او
خلق قوه ردع او حقق معادله جديده وهذا
يعني امر معقد ايضا دعنا نكون نتنياهو
يعني هو
حذر جدا في مساله التوجه الى مواجهات
مفتوحه وهو يعني محاط بائتلاف اشكالي جدا
وهذا اتلاف لا يساعده في يعني تسويق
المسوغ الذي يمكن ان يقوده ويقدمه للعالم
من اجل ارتكاب مجازر وربما جرائم في قطاع
غزه لا تتوفر له الظروف المناسبه
نعم نعم تماما وكل هذا يجعلنا نفترض انه
بالفعل يعني الامور تميل اكثر يعني كما
انه لدى مصر نفوذ كبير على قطاع غزه وهي
رئه قطاع غزه عمليا
وقنواتها مفتوحه وسلسه الاتصالات فيها معك
مع الطرفين ايضا الولايات المتحده لها
نفود كبير على اسرائيل واذا يعني الطرفين
اتفقوا على انه هذا ليس وقت التصعيد لا
يخدم ربما يعقد هذا يعني يسحب من يد
نتنياهو هامش كبير على المناوره وانا
اعيدك الى المشاورات الامنيه التي اجراها
عندما يجد مشاركه امنيه بعيدا عن
هذه المشاورات وفقط يحظر الكبريت ليصوتوا
على قرارات اغلبيه فيها وتعيده الابد بعد
ان كان بالاره نتنياهو مع اجهزه الامن
بعيدا عنهم لان هذا يريد ان يبقي الخيوط
بيده والا يعني ينجر وينجرف خلف المتطرفين
الذين يدعون الى الاغتيالات والتصعيد
والرد بشكل اقصى واقوى من ذلك نعم طيب
نتحول الى قطاع غزه الصحفي نضال الخضراء
اهلا بك من جديد يعني دعم يعني ضعنا الان
في صوره ما يحدث الان صف لنا شوارع غزه في
هذا التوقيت تحديدا يعني حيث انت
من الناس
لانه في ظل هذه الاجواء يعني الناس تلتزم
بيوتها خوفا من من استهداف او عمليات
اغتيال خاصه ان يعني الشعب الفلسطيني في
قطاع غزه من خلال
التجارب مع هذا الاحتلال ان هذا الاحتلال
لا يؤمن مكروه من الممكن ان يستهدف بنايات
من الممكن ان يستهدف بنيه تحتيه بحجه ضرب
انفاق
ومن الممكن ان يستهدف اي شيء ففي هذه
اللحظات او في لحظات التصعيد المواطنين في
قطاع غزه يلتزموا بيوتهم بيوتهم
ويحصنوا انفسهم ويراقبوا ويتابع الاخبار
عن كثب
الان يعني
غزه خاليه وهناك ترقب من خلال وسائل
الاعلام من عن اسطح البنايات العاليه لرفض
يعني
الرشقات الصاروخيه التي تختقها المقاومه
باتجاه الاحتلال ورد ايضا
يعني القصف الطيران قصف الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي
لاي مواقع سيما ان يعني
هناك يعني غزه منطقه مقسمه يعني محدوده
يعني من الممكن ان يعني ان
في شمال قطاع غزه من بعض الاماكن المرتفعه
من الممكن ان ترصد منطقه شمال غزه من
مدينه غزه من بعض الابراج المرتفعه من
الممكن ان ترصد مدينه في غزه المدينه وك
في كل منطقه سواء من رفح خان يونس المنطقه
الوسطى قطاع غزه شمال قطاع غزه الان يعني
وسائل الاعلام كلها يعني تترقب الجميع
يتابع ونحن يعني خاصه ان غدا هو يوم
الجمعه الجمعه الثالثه في رمضان وان
الفلسطينيين يعني ذاهبون للصلاه وان هناك
يعني تهديدات من منظمه عائدون لجبل الهيكل
المنظمه الصهيونيه التي دعت لذبح القرابين
في المسجد الاقصى الجميع يتحسب الجميع
يترقب الجميع في حاله ترقب وخاصه اليوم
محي الشمال وتواريخ التي اطلقت من من
لبنان باتجاه مستوطنات في الشمال كان حدث
فارق من الممكن يعني ان ااا
قواعد الاشتباك يعني ان يغير القواعد
والان يعني اسرائيل قصفت لحد هذه اللحظه
لم
نحن نتابع لم تعلن اي جهه في لبنان عن
طبيعه الاهداف التي قصفتها
اسرائيل
باستثناء الاعلان اعلان جيش الدفاع
الاسرائيلي ان ان اسرائيل قامت بقصف
مواقع لحماس في في جنوب لبنان هذا الذي تم
الاعلان عنه لم نتابع لحد هذه اللحظه اي
جهه في لبنان يعني اعلنت عن طبيعه
الاستهداف الذي تم في لبنان
وما زلنا نتوقع ان اسرائيل من الممكن ان
تمارس سياسه التضليل وان تذهب
هي لم تذهب
لمواجهه او احتكاك مباشر في حزب الله لانه
هذا سيكون تداعياته خطيره من وجهه نظري
انا باعتقادي ان اسرائيل من الممكن ان
تذهب لاستهداف بعض قاعده المقاومه في
لبنان وسوريا على غرار عمليه الاغتيال
التي نخلتها في في العشرين من الشهر
الماضي بحق القياده في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي على الاسود الذي
ادعت انه هو الذي هو المسؤول عن ارسال
المقتحم الذي اقتحم
الجليل
[موسيقى]
في نصف العاصمه السوريه دمشق يعني قبل
قليل كان مراسل العربيه زميلنا زياد افاد
باطلاق صواريخ من قطاع غزه باتجاه
مستوطنات الغلاف وافاده ايضا باصابه
مستوطن جراء سقوط صاروخ على منزل فيزيرات
يعني هل لديك تفاصيل وانت موجود الان في
غزه
لا هناك يعني
اعلان الان
للمتحدث الدفاع الاسرائيلي يقول ان
الطائرات المقاتله قامت قبل قليل بشن
غارات على اهداف اضافيه تتبع لحركه حماس
في قطاع غزه وهو يعني يحمل حركه حماس
مسؤوليه كل ما يجري ويقول انه هي ستدفع
ثمن الانتهاكات الامنيه ضد اسرائيل
هذا التصريح الصادر الان
عن المتحدث باسم الجيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي
لكن
مش ليس بالضروره ان ان ناخذ هذه التصريحات
على محمل الجلد
لان يعني السلوك كما قلت لك من خلال
المتابعه السلوك الان يؤكد لحد هذه اللحظه
ان المقاومه واسرائيل لن يتجاوزها حدود
قواعد الاشتباك
لا يوجد شهداء في قطاع غزه لا يوجد قصف
منشات لا يوجد قصف بنيه تحتيه كل القصف
يتركز حول مواقع عسكريه تتبع للمقاومه
اضافه لصواريخ المقاومه لحد هذه اللحظه
المقاومه لم تطلق صواريخ استراتيجيه بعيده
المدى تتجاوز تتجاوزك في او تتجاوز غلاف
غزه مستوطنات غلاف غزه
لحد هذه اللحظه انا بتقدير ان الامور تحت
السيطره سيما ان هناك تدخل من الامم
المتحده وتدخل من المصريين وهناك يعني
اخبار وصلت لنا
[موسيقى]
خاصه ان كما قلت لك هناك تباين كبير وهناك
مشكله كبيره في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تحديدا بين الاجهزه الامنيه والجيش وبين
وزير الامن الوطني اعتمار بن كبير هذا
الفاشي الذي
يجهر بالعداء ويدعو للقتل والعنف ضد
الفلسطينيين بصلف بشكل يعني بصراحه مستفز
هل ستستطيع الاجهزه الامنيه يعني ان تكبح
جماح هذا الارهابي
من دعمه للمستوطنين
خاصه اننا راينا قبل ذلك يعني قبل قبل ذلك
ان اعتماد بن كبير تحدى الجيش وتحدى الامن
وقام بقياده مسيره المستوطنين واقتحم
المسجد الاقصى هناك يعني احصائيات شهدناها
انه يعني ضرب قرار الاجهزه الامنيه بعرض
الحائط بشكل سافر وتحدي الاجهزه الامنيه
واقتحم المسجد الاقصى هل غدا سيتم السيطره
على هذا
المجنون نعم يبقى معنا
صحفي نضال الخضراء من غزه
نتابع معكم مشاهدينا يعني هذه التغطيه على
الهواء مباشره
لهذه الغاره الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت
قطاع غزه وايضا استهدفت مواقع تقول
اسرائيل بانها تتبع
لحركه حماس وايضا هي مواقع لانتاج سلاح
كما ذكر الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه الغاره لم
تكن الوحيده بعد ان عاد الهدوء الحذر الى
حد ما في قطاع غزه يعني تحول تحولت هذه
الغاره الى جنوب لبنان بالتحديد الى مخيم
الرشيديه للاجئين الفلسطينيين
وقامت باستهداف هذا
المخيم كذلك يعني تواصلت يعني هذه الغاره
وصلت الى سته صواريخ على منطقه صور في
جنوب لبنان الان هذه الصور المباشره التي
تاتينا من قطاع غزه ليله طويله ليله صعبه
ليله كان فيها
الكثير من القلق والترقب حتى نحن في وسائل
الاعلام يعني الكل يتابع لحظه بلحظه ما
يجري في قطاع غزه وما يجري ايضا في جنوب
لبنان وما يجري في المسجد الاقصى يعني هذه
التغطيه كانت لحظه بلحظه منذ ان بدا
الاقتحام قبل ثلاثه ايام الى باحات المسجد
الاقصى حيث قامت القوات الاسرائيليه باقتح
المسجد الاقصى وبمنع المصلين والمعتكفين
في هذا المسجد من البقاء في المسجد وقامت
باجلاء المصلين بالقوه بعد ذلك
تطورت الامور بشكل كبير وبشكل متسارع يعني
الى ان
اطلقت يعني صباح امس صواريخ يعني عديده من
جنوب لبنان الى الداخل
الاسرائيلي اكثر من 30 صاروخا استهدفوا
مناطق مختلفه في الداخل
الاسرائيلي اثر ذلك كان الرد بعد اجتماع
الاسرائيلي الخليه الامنيه يعني وقبل ان
ينتهي وقبل ان ينفض سامر هذا الاجتماع
قامت القوات
الاسرائيليه
يعني شنغاره على قطاع غزه مستهد مناطق
تقول اسرائيل بانها تتبع لي حركه حماس بعد
ذلك بطبيعه الحال تحولت الوجهه وجهه سلاح
الطيران الاسرائيلي الى جنوب لبنان
واستهدفت مخيم الراشديه بسته صواريخ
سياسيا تتفاعل هذه يعني القضيه بشكل كبير
هنالك مساعي مصريه امريكيه هذه الوساطه
استطاعت حتى الان الى ان تعيد الامور الى
مرحله الهدوء الحذر الذي نتابعه ويعني
نقله لنا الزملاء يعني في قطاع غزه وايضا
من مختلف المناطق تحدثوا عن عوده الهدوء
الحذر الى قطاع غزه بعد هذه الغاره
الاسرائيليه التي تحدث عنها البعض بانها
كانت محدوده وبالمقابل كان الرد محدود الى
حد ما من قبل الفص الفلسطينيه ونحن نتحدث
حتى الان الكل ينتظر اذا كانت هنالك اي رد
فعل من من حماس الكل ينتظر ايضا اذا كان
هنالك رد فعل من حزب الله في في لبنان
الكل ينتظر ما ستؤول اليه الامور عقب صلاه
الجمعه الجمعه الثالثه في شهر رمضان يعني
الكل يترقب ما يمكن ان يحدث زميلنا ومدير
مكتب العربيه في القدس زياد حلبي كان قد
تحدث بشكل وافي وواضح عن ان هنالك تدابير
اتخذتها السلطات الامنيه في القدس وربما
يعني ستمنع الكثير من المصلين من الوصول
الى المسجد الاقصى وربما هذا بحسب البعض
طبعا يفتح الباب لمزيد من التصعيد وحاله
الاحتقان التي تتزايد بطبيعه الحال عقب كل
حدث وعقب كل غاره اسرائيليه وعقب ايضا كل
اقتحام لباحات المسجد الاقصى لا ادري اذا
كان يعني زياد حلبي معنا الان ام لا
نعم زياد
انا معك هل من معلومات جديده سياسيا هل
هنالك اي ردود افعال رصدتها يعني قبل قليل
طبعا لا جديد في على صعيد ردود الافعال في
اسرائيل هناك استمرار حاليا لقص متقطع
متبادل في قطاع غزه هناك توتر في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك بعد عفوا ان قام
المصلون بعد صلاه الفجر
بمظاهره في ساحات المسجد الاقصى عمليا
وهناك تضيقات واعتداءات اسرائيليه هذا كان
متوقع طبعا قلنا ان المحاكم سيكون صلاه
الجمعه الثالثه في شهر رمضان اليوم
بطبيعه الحال اليوم لا يوجد اقتحامات
للمستوطنين اليوم وغدا وبالتالي هذا
الموضوع قد يكون يعني مختلفا بالنسبه
للجبه هنا في لبنان الامور تبدو هادئه
الان الفجر عمليا بدا الصباح يظهر الامور
تبدو هادئه على هذه الجبهه فقط تتواصل
الامور تصعيدا في جبهه قطاع غزه بشكل او
باخر نعم زياده ومع شروق الشمس لدي دقيقه
يعني واحده او اقل من ذلك هل نستطيع ان
نقول عمليا بان هذه العمليه العسكريه
لاسرائيل قد انتهت ام ان يعني هذه العمليه
حتى الان لم تبح بكل اسرارها
في الشق اللبناني تبدو وكانها انتهت طبعا
في حال لم يقم حزب الله باطلاق صواريخ ردا
على الاستهداف بالغارات الاسرائيليه قد
تكون اقفل الملف على الجبهه اللبنانيه
بشكل مؤقت لان المواجهه مع حزب الله ليست
اساسا في الاراضي اللبنانيه هي في سوريا
بشكل كبير فيما يتعلق بقطاع غزه ايضا
الامور تابلو قابله للاحتواء النهار اليوم
ببساطه مصريه وضغوط امريكيه
وما الى ذلك لكن التوتر الجوال انجاز
التعبير مع توحيد الساحات يبقى قائما
وبطبيعه الحال اسرائيل تستطيع ان تعمل
ايضا وهي تفضل الجغرافيا السوريه على كل
هذه الجبهات لانها اقل كلفه وهناك عمليه
تنفذ غارات ضد الايرانيين وضد حزب الله
وضد ايضا قياديين في الفصائل الفلسطينيه
سبق واغتالت قيادي في الجهاد في دمشق الى
ذلك وبالتالي تستطيع ان تستمر في هذا
الموضوع مدير مكتب العربيه زياد حلبي شكرا
جزيلا لك كنت معنا من الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه اذن يعني اعود الى الزميل صهيب
صهيب يعني اقتربت الشمس في قطاع غزه وفي
القدس وايضا في الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه اقتربت الشمس من الاشراق
اتمنى ان يعود الهدوء الى تلك المنطقه
زميل زياد يقول ان الهدوء عاد بالفعل
واتمنى قبل اكتمال شروق الشمس يعود الهدوء
بشكل كامل
على عكس الليله الفائته ولكن نبقي اعيننا
طبعا اولا باول على التطورات على الجبهتين
على قطاع غزه وعلى جنوب لبنان ايضا